Begleitet von massiven Vorwürfen des Wahlbetrugs
ist Russlands Präsident Wladimir Putin mit
Dreiviertelmehrheit im Amt bestätigt worden.
Putin kommt Prognosen zufolge auf fast 74
Prozent der Stimmen.
Die Opposition und die Wahlbeobachtergruppe
Golos prangern massive Verstöße bei der
Wahl an.
"Zum einen geht es um das Vollstopfen der
Wahlurnen.
Das Internet ist voll von Videos von Überwachungskameras,
die zeigen, wie Leute einen Packen Stimmzettel
in die Wahlurnen stecken.
Das passiert überall im Land."
Diese Bilder einer Überwachungskamera aus
einem Wahllokal bei Moskau sollen zeigen,
wie Wahlhelfer eine Urne mit Stimmzetteln
vollstopfen.
Das Beobachterteam von Kreml-Kritiker Nawalny
ist auf noch mehr Unregelmäßigkeiten gestoßen.
Es hat nach eigenen Angaben mehr als 33.000
Beobachter in Wahlbüros in ganz Russland entsandt.
"Ein Haupttrend ist das massive Herankarren
von Wählern in Bussen.
Wir haben Berichte darüber aus allen Regionen.
Das organisierte Herankarren von Wählern
ist wie Bestechung.
Sie werden zur Stimmabgabe an die Wahllokale
gefahren."
Nawalny hätte Putin als einziger gefährlich
werden können.
Er war jedoch wegen einer gerichtlichen Verurteilung
von der Wahl ausgeschlossen worden.
Die anderen Kandidaten waren von vornherein
chancenlos.